there are a couple of problems with
Second Life one is that the graphics are
incredibly crude and you know it just
doesn't work very well but the other one
what is that the other problem in second
life is that essentially there are no
rules there are no goals you know it's
not a game you know games are a
structured experience we know where
we're we're given rules to follow and
goals to achieve and you know that's
what makes them so compelling you know
whether it's World of Warcraft or chess
and and and second life doesn't have
those and you know virtual reality you
know I'm not really sure where that's
going to go but it's certainly at the
moment doesn't have the kind of you know
appeal it hasn't seized the imagination
the way it did a few years ago what is
happening though is that by turning you
know entertainment properties by turning
stories into a kind of participatory
experience they begin to become like
games themselves you know the thing
about a game video games especially is
that you know you're the protagonist you
know you become the you become the
character that everything is happening
to it really thrusts you into the middle
of this world and and and you know you
you know totally engage with it so you
know I think that's one of the places
where things like this are going there
have been several different you know
experiments you know ways of you know
trying to figure out how to how to take
advantage of this you know one is
alternate reality games which tend to be
you know very long drawn-out experiences
that engage people on any number of
levels from you know a casual you know
involvement of where people just go to a
website and
and look at what's happening to you know
very very active where you know they
sort of applied their minds to saw being
a whole you know series of riddles and
puzzles and so forth but these these
things tend to take place over mean you
know many months and they're not really
replicable you know once it's over it's
over you know what other people are
starting to experiment now with is is
experiences that last more like you know
10 minutes 15 minutes in that you know
happened to you when you set something
in motion for example you know you go to
a website for a movie and you're into
your phone number and and a few minutes
later your phone rings and you know
perhaps you're thrust into the middle of
a of a situation that has to you know
like has to do with the thriller that
you're that you're dealing with so you
know the I don't think these things have
been perfected either but it's a it's a
really intriguing a way of looking at
entertainment
well one very interesting manifestations
certainly is what anthony zacchara is
doing this is a guy who created the CSI
series he's you know single handedly
made forensics a major subject of study
in American universities and he's
essentially moving on from that and
creating a whole different a series of
entertainment properties that you know
really engage people on a number of
different levels the first one which is
going to introduce at comic-con in San
Diego this July and which will be
available for sale starting I believe
September 8 is a series of novels
thrillers that incorporate not only text
but but video which you can watch on the
web or which you can you know on your on
your iphone or your itouch you can you
know do the whole thing you can read it
and then watch the video and go back to
reading again you know this points up to
a whole new way of you know experiencing
novels say you know you it's constructed
so that you don't have to watch the
video if you don't want to or if it's
not available to you you know wherever
you happen to be at the moment but if
you do it gives you you know a little
something extra it gives you you know a
kind of a deeper understanding of what's
happening and frankly given that this is
a thriller about it about a serial
killer a pretty scary understanding of
what's happening or what could be
happening and there's also going to be a
website involved of course which will
enable people to you know talk to each
other about it you know sort of
communicate online you know participate
in the whole thing in one level or
another and it's it's you know again
it's a bit of an experiment but it's a
very you know
bold an interesting experiment and you
know I think this is clearly someone who
has shown himself to be a master
storyteller and we'll see where he takes
us
papers are you know rapidly evolving if
they're going to be successful at least
into you know websites that incorporate
all kinds of different media and that
you know incorporate the the reader as
well and in the in the whole experience
you know obviously if you're if if
you're going to some website to you know
learn about some news development what
you really want is you know not just to
be able to to to read the text about it
although you certainly want that but you
also want to be able to watch video but
whatever it is that's happening you want
to have maps you know sort of flash
interactive experiences that that you
know take you into the story and give
you a deeper understanding of it and you
know you want you want and expect to be
able to you know express your opinion
about it you know they're on the site to
communicate with other people about it
and you know really you know the news is
I think fast becoming a great experience
it's no longer something that you you
know sit there in isolation at your
kitchen table reading the you know
reading the newspaper in the morning
we already live in an attention economy
essentially you know where the where the
where the real scarcity is you know is
is is you know attention you know is you
know getting attention in people's minds
and you know I think that's um you know
only going to you know only going to
become more so and you know what's
what's happening with this kind of depth
of experience that that you know
internet storytelling offers is that you
know some people will be you know sucked
deeper and deeper so to speak into into
particular stories and you know
obviously ignore other ones entirely you
know I and I think that goes for any
kind of story whether it's a you know a
science-fiction say you know
entertainment whether it's a marketing
message that you know a company like
Nike for example or coke gets you to you
know sort of sucks you into and kind of
game-like experience whether it's you
know whether it's the news and I think
you know one clear you know ramification
of this is that you know we're just
becoming more and more connected i mean
the internet obviously is connecting us
anyway but but this gives us saints to
connect on and in an opportunity to you
know to really do so so that it you know
becomes relatively easy to go from you
know reading about something or or
watching something to acting on it and
acting on it with you know with other
people as well